und auch von mir ein ganz herzliches
willkommen zur heutigen gemeinsamen
pressekonferenz ich muss zugeben kein
ganz normaler arbeitstag aber ich glaube
es hat sich gelohnt die nacht
durchzumachen
bevor ich jetzt mit dem ende beginner
lassen sie uns 20 monate zurück gehen
ungefähr in den herbst 2009 10 als wir
im rahmen einer anderen
ermittlungskommission hinweise erhielten
und sich die auch verdichteten auf die
kriminellen machenschaften eine arabisch
stämmigen großfamilie in leverkusen mit
aktivitäten in ganz nordrhein westfalen
das waren städte in wuppertal in
duisburg in köln leverkusen und in
düsseldorf wo mit ja dann auch erstmal
die polizei in düsseldorf ins spiel
kommt was haben wir da gemacht
wir haben eine recht starke
ermittlungskommission eingerichtet die
uca dienststelle in düsseldorf hat dann
erstmal angefangen zu ermitteln
ich glaube dass die ergebnisse zeigen
gezeigt haben dass es sich lohnt und
dass ein langer atem bei der bekämpfung
der kleinkriminalität sich letztlich
auszahlt was sich für unsere familie er
nicht bezahlt gemacht hat und ausgezahlt
hat waren die verschiedenen delikte die
sie begangen haben
zumindest den verdacht haben wir
erhalten dass sie eben unter anderem
einen sozialleistungsbetrug gewerbsmäßig
und bandenmäßig begangenen haben sie
schutzgeld erpressungen begangen haben
und letztlich das geld das sie so
erlangt haben auch waschen wollte und
sich damit verdächtig gemacht haben der
geldwäsche
was steht sonst noch im raum
rauschgiftgeschäfte haben wir darauf
haben wir hinweise wir haben auch
hinweise auf die fälschung von gruner
tests ein ganz heikles thema moment und
insgesamt auch den hinweis darauf dass
unser 46 jährige familienoberhaupt als
sogenannter schlichter innerhalb und
außerhalb des clans tätig war
das heißt dass man immer irgendwelche
streitigkeiten gibt werden diese
schlichter gefragt ob sie eben helfen
können dadurch bekommen sie erhalten sie
ganz unterschiedlich hohe summen je nach
streitgegenstand und was diese parallel
muss die diese parallelwelt erst richtig
deutlich macht ist glaube ich
das sind das sanktionssystem dass das
dann durch die familie durchgesetzt wird
dann nach diesen schlichtungen irgendein
schlichterspruch getan wurde und dann
entweder keine zahlung eingegangen ist
oder diesen gewünschten verhalten nicht
nachgekommen ist dann gab es eben auch
entsprechende sanktion
wir haben so also den hinweis darauf
erlangt das vermögen umfangreiches
vermögen mit hilfe von straftaten
erworben wurden das haben die intensiven
finanz ermittlungen sowohl der
düsseldorfer polizei als auch des
landeskriminalamts gezeigt und auch
weitere verdachtsmomente erbracht und
das betrifft vor allem die
sozialleistungen die über jahre bezogen
wurden und das obwohl offensichtlich
überhaupt gar keine rechtliche grundlage
dafür bestand wurde getan
es wurden bedarfsgemeinschaften gebildet
innerhalb dieser familie
man hat das jobcenter mit unwahren
angaben versehen man hat wahre angaben
gemacht man hat im prinzip vom versucht
vorzutäuschen dass man nahezu mittellos
ist
ich glaube was wir heute gefunden haben
sie werden schon gesehen haben in ihrem
rücken beweist das gegenteil
da ist keine nahezu mittellos oder
annähernd mittellose familie sondern
eine die ein vermögen aufgebaut hat und
da haben wir gesagt das geht nicht da
müssen wir dran und ich möchte in diesem
zusammenhang was sagen es ist von mai
bis 2015 bis heute und ich meine heute
nicht gestern ich meine tatsächlich
heute dieser familie gelungen mit eben
sehr großer krimineller energie über
400.000 euro zu beziehen zu unrecht zu
beziehen und das ist geld das sie dass
ich in den steuern den sozialstaat
einzahlen um denjenigen zu helfen die
tatsächlich schwächer sind in unserer
gesellschaft in dem zusammenhang möchte
ich verdeutlichen kriminelles vermögen
ist kein vermögen und das wird auch
nicht legalisiert dadurch dass es
illegale geschäfte eingezahlt wird oder
investiert wird und das hat unsere
familie versucht hat versucht einen
legalen finanzfluss vorzutäuschen indem
sie investiert hat ein autoverleih
firmen in die baubranche in
friseursalons sogenannte barbara shops
in dem fall und ich finde noch besonders
verwerflich in den vertrieb von
medizinischen produkten in der heutigen
zeit all das inkriminierte vermögen das
so versucht werden sollte gewaschen zu
werden
ich finde was dem ganzen noch die krone
aufsetzt ist wie mit ihrer hilfe um
meiner dieser familie ist gelungen ist
oder gelingen würde wenn wir dem jetzt
nicht einhalt geboten hätte ihr
familiäres ja man muss sagen anwesenden
leverkusen zu finanzieren
das haben insbesondere die finanz
ermittler des lka nachgewiesen dazu wird
der jung wird nachher noch ausführungen
machen das werden sie sich auch nachher
wirklich anschauen können da drüben so
hat vielleicht zu den ermittlungen
was haben die ermittlungen gebracht wir
haben zum jetzigen zeitpunkt mehr als 30
beschuldigte für die vier haftbefehle
erwirkt wurden über 30 durchsuchungs
objekte wohnungen häuser büro und
geschäftsräume
wir haben außerdem fünf vermögensrechte
in einer gesamthöhe von 789 1000 euro
also knapp 790.000 euro erwirken können
und wir sehen eben nicht weg wenn
kriminelle wenn es kriminellen gelingt
durch straftaten oder auf kosten des
sozialstaats reich zu werden
und das zeigt sich glaube ich auch herr
röhrl hat es ja schon angedeutet wollen
in seiner pressekonferenz die wegnahme
der villa auch das ein verdienst des lka
da ist es gelungen eben einen
beschlagnahmebeschluss zu erwirken und
der familie ebenso zumindest einen teil
ihrer existenzgrundlage zu nehmen man
muss sich das noch mal vor augen halten
aus meiner sicht kann das nicht sein
dass eine familie die sozialleistungen
bezieht noch mal zu unrecht wie man da
hinten sieht in einer villa wohnt dem
ungefähr oder etwa eine million euro
wert ist und sie und ich wir kommen
dafür auf tut mir leid aber da da platzt
mir der kragen
und deswegen haben wir heute etwas getan
ich möchte auch diese an der stelle eben
für diesen gemeinsamen einsatz den wir
heute durchgeführt haben all meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen den
eingesetzten kräften und dienststellen
die mit ganz ganz viel fleißarbeit uns
im vorfeld und mit einem tollen
engagement heute diesen einsatz so
professionell bewältigt haben und ich
darf aussagen zum teil noch dabei sind
ihn zu bewältigen
da möchte ich mal ein ganz ganz
herzliches dankeschön loswerden
nützlich wenn plötzlich vor stolz aber
es hat nicht nur mein verdienst oder im
ganz wesentliche nicht mein verdienst
sondern das meiner kolleginnen und
kollegen und der alle eingesetzten
kräfte vielen dank
eins muss ich leider an dieser stelle
aussagen da meine kollegin die sich
leicht verletzt hat heute im einsatz
da würde ich an dieser stelle sehr sehr
gern ein paar genesungswünsche loswerden
und hoffe dass wir bald wieder auf die
beine kommt im wahrsten sinne des wortes
das aber nur leicht verletzt so fand
trotzdem herzliche grüße von jungs ich
weiß sie warten darauf was ist denn
jetzt eigentlich das ergebnis außer dem
was sie da hinten sehen
ich glaube das kann sie auf jeden fall
sehen lassen wir haben die vier
haftbefehle natürlich vollstreckt zum
teil mit unterstützung von
spezialeinheiten
es wurden dabei keine personen verletzt
dass das ganze nicht immer so ohne
sachschäden vonstatten geht davon glaube
ich konnte sich ein teil von ihnen
selbst überzeugen
an dem anwesen in leverkusen aber wenn
das zur gewährleistung der sicherheit
unserer einsatzkräfte notwendig ist dann
müssen wir dieses risiko eingehen
die durchsuchung an einigen wenigen
objekten dauern derzeit noch an
insbesondere das anwesen in leverkusens
aufgrund der größe noch in bearbeitung
an diesem objekt haben wir auch
spezielle technik eingesetzt die mit der
wir nach geld oder anderen verstecken in
böden im erdreich und in wänden suchen
können
da bin ich noch ganz gespannt auf das
ergebnis das werden wir werde ich später
erfahren dazu kann ich noch nicht sagen
aber ich kann jetzt schon sagen wir
haben ganz ganz viel bargeld gefunden
die höhe insgesamt steht noch nicht fest
aber es sind jetzt schon mindestens 335
tausend euro bargeld davon ungefähr
290.000 alleine
stück in leverkusen also bei der familie
die angegeben hat nahezu mittellos zu
sagen was haben wir noch gefunden
ein sturmgewehr ak-47 mit verschlossenem
lauf also unbrauchbar gemacht weil wir
nicht genau noch nicht genau sagen
können ob das relativ schnell wieder
rückgängig zu machen ist aber ich glaube
selbst wenn man so ein gewehr mal vor
die nase bekommt es ganz egal ob das
unbrauchbar ist oder nicht wird seine
wirkung nicht verfehlen tut mir
insbesondere nicht in den kreisen in
denen dann auch bekannt ist das eben
auch mit scharfen schusswaffen hantiert
wird und die haben wir auch gefunden
haben zwei schafe 9mm pistole gefunden
weitere ptb waffen auch eine eine
softair-pistole wir haben eine brief
grundschuld für über 200.000 euro
gefunden
darüber hat mir vorher kenntnis die
haben tatsächlich auffinden können und
werden die auch in den vermögens rs mit
einbeziehen können
es gibt einige fahrzeuge die wir
sichergestellt haben unter anderem einen
korb das wert von 25.000 euro ebenfalls
zur vollstreckung des vermögens arrestes
beiträgt und ein mercedes vito eine
armbanduhr im wert von 30.000 euro genau
das was man auch mal hört wie die
kleinen kriminellen daneben auch ihr
geld ausgeben
schmuck weiteren schmuck eben luxus
taschen wahrscheinlich plagiate das
müssen wir noch mal checken
außerdem noch immer 19 blanco
bescheinigungen die aber schon mit einem
stempel und eine unterschrift versehen
sind über corona tests und ansonsten
noch diverse dokumente und ja jede menge
als erwartet
wie geht es jetzt weiter waren lange
einsatz
aber der ist noch nicht zu ende
insbesondere nicht der einsatz der
kolleginnen und kollegen ich kann gleich
schlafen gehen aber die wir natürlich
noch beschäftigt seien mit dem sortieren
der ganzen asservate und dann im
nachgang natürlich mit der auswertung
der umfangreichen vernehmungen von
zeugen und beschuldigten und dann muss
man gucken natürlich was diese
ermittlungen ergeben auch für weitere
hinweise auf weitere straftaten finden
und ich sag mal dann geht das ganze zwar
nicht von vorne los aber dann geht das
ganze weiter und ich hoffe dass wir dann
vielleicht uns demnächst noch nicht ganz
so lange hin aber wieder treffen und
einen weiteren erfolgreichen schlag hin
kleinkriminalität zusammen begeistert
feiern können
bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob ich was
vergessen habe aber da vorher die
fragerunde insofern gebe ich jetzt
erstmal zurück an den strafraum schulz
vielen herzlichen dank für den
erfrischenden vortrag herr sterzel sie
dürfen sich jetzt auf die rechtlichen
fragen stürzend viel erfolg ja danke
schön auch von meiner seite noch einmal
herzlich willkommen
als allererstes sie haben mich auch bei
allen am einsatz beteiligten kräften
heute bedanken
insbesondere natürlich bei den
ermittlungskommission vom
polizeipräsidium düsseldorf und dem lka
für die wirklich hervorragende
zusammenarbeit
sie haben den sachverhalt gehört ich
darf ihn jetzt vielleicht vielleicht
darf ich jetzt eine kurze rechtliche
einschätzung dieses sachverhaltes
präsentieren
ja ja der haupttat vorwurf den wir
zunächst haben's der des gewerbsmäßigen
betruges
der ist strafbar nach 263 absatz 5
strafgesetzbuch und stützt sich
hauptsächlich auf die den bezug der
sozialleistungen also nach dem jetzigen
stand der ermittlungen gehen wir davon
aus dass die beschuldigten spätestens
2015 den part entschluss gefasst haben
gemeinsam und im wechselseitigen
zusammen wirkungen betrugs straftaten zu
begehen und zwar zum nachteil des
jobcenters in leverkusen
insgesamt haben die beschuldigten im
zeitraum mai 2015 bis april 2021 drei
bedarfsgemeinschaften angemeldet beim
jobcenter in leverkusen und haben über
die eingereichten unterlagen den
eindruck erweckt dass sie aufgrund
mangelnder einkommens und
vermögenssituation oder einer schlechten
situation in anspruch auf
sozialleistungen haben obwohl das
tatsächlich nicht der fall war
nach dem jetzigen erkenntnisstand haben
die beschuldigten in dem zeitraum über
erhebliche einkünfte aus bisher
unbekannten quellen verfügt die sie
haben ja schon gehört was man allein für
bargeldbestände in der in der immobilie
sichergestellten konnte 290.000 euro an
bargeld habe ich nicht zu hause
da stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
jemand der sozialleistung bezieht über
so ein
ja bargeld vermögen verfügen kann
außerdem haben wir erkenntnisse da ist
über strohleute immobilien erworben
wurden oder aber sich über auch
strohleute an firmengründungen beteiligt
wurde
alles mit dem ziel der gewinnmaximierung
die finanz finanz ermittlungen haben
ergeben dass allein im zeitraum oktober
2010 bis oktober 2000 bis mai 20 20 die
familie über einen hohen sechsstelligen
betrag verfügen konnte und damit
tatsächlich geschäfte tätigen konnte von
daher gehen wir davon aus dass die
beschuldigten gewerbsmäßig gehandelt
haben da sie sich durch diese
wiederholte antragsstellung natürlich
und auch die gründung der der
bedarfsgemeinschaften ja eine
fortlaufende einnahmequelle von nicht
unerheblichem umfang und von einiger
dauer verschafft haben
das ganze haben sie auch als bande
gemacht da sie nicht nur aufgrund ihrer
verwandtschaftlichen zusammengehörigkeit
als familie verbunden sind sondern eben
auch die einen dazu ein
familiengeführtes unternehmen betrieben
haben das arbeitsteilig strukturiert war
und das ziel der gewinnmaximierung
verfolgt hat da kann man tatsächlich
sagen das familienoberhaupt java hatte
den überblick über oder hatte auch die
entscheidungsbefugnis über das das
familienvermögen konnte entscheiden
welche investitionen getätigt werden an-
und verkäufe von wertgegenständen et
cetera
dann gab es eine art kassenwartin die
dann den zufluss also wie eine
buchhalterin die den zufluss der
vermögen des vermögens verwaltet hat und
einen überblick darüber hatte und dann
wurde durch weitere beschuldigte daran
gearbeitet die verschleierung des
familienvermögens zu betreiben so dass
nach außen in eben der schein einer
mittellosen familie gewagt werden konnte
insgesamt gehen wir von einem
gesamtschaden von über 400.000 euro aus
die durch den bezug von den
sozialleistungen verursacht wurden
des weiteren laufen ermittlungen wegen
des verdachts der geldwäsche das liegt
ganz einfach daran das familienvermögen
das durch kriminelle geschäfte aufgebaut
wurde dann durch einbringung in den
legalen wirtschaftskreislauf gewaschen
werden sollte
da sprechen wir insbesondere vom erwerb
von immobilien und auch beteiligungen an
firmen durch strohleute beispielsweise
wurden darlehen auch zum erwerb des
anwesens auf dem heute die
durchsuchungen stattgefunden haben
wurden die darlehen teilweise durch den
bezug der sozialleistungen der familie
mitglieder finanziert ansonsten kann ich
noch vielleicht kurz was zur
vermögenssicherung sagen die betrieben
wurde wir haben vermögens arrest
vollstreckt sie haben wir schon gehört
in höhe von knapp 790 1000 euro die
vermögensrechte sind ein mittel zur
sicherung des anspruchs auf einziehung
den am späteren gerichtsverfahren
beispielsweise tatmittel oder aber eben
auch tat erträge so soll sichergestellt
werden dass keine vermögensverschiebung
durch die beschuldigten also sofern die
beschuldigten kenntnis von den
ermittlungen verlangen er lange besteht
natürlich immer der die befürchtung dass
vermögens vermögenswerte noch verschoben
werden
veräußerungen stattfinden vermögenswerte
auch verschenkt werden einfach nur um
sie dann dem staatlichen zugriff zu
entziehen
und genau durch die verschrecken solche
vermögens erste die wir erwirkt und auch
versteckt haben soll das verhindert
werden
das geschieht dann beispielsweise durch
die beschlagnahme von beweglichen
wertgegenständen die dann mitgenommen
werden oder aber auch das kann man den
immobilien verstrickt werden
sie haben ja auch schon gehört wir haben
eine immobilie beschlagnahmt das ist
immobilien leverkusen insofern wird da
eine beschlagnahme vermerken grundbuch
eingetragen und führt dann letztlich
dazu dass die beschuldigten über diese
immobilie nicht mehr verfügen können das
heißt sie können sie nicht
weiterveräußern
und damit es auch erstmal dass dieser
vermögenswerte gesichert
ja alles in allem denke ich dass der
heutige einsatz gezeigt hat wie gut die
langfristige zusammenarbeit zwischen
staatsanwaltschaft und polizei hier
polizeipräsidium düsseldorf und lka
funktioniert und
bekräftigt auch nochmal wie elementar
wichtig und wie wirkungsvoll gründliche
finanz ermittlungen und auch die
vermögensabschöpfung hin sind
hinsichtlich der bekämpfung des delikts
phänomens der kleinkriminalität
dankeschön